i got a question from dylan and dylan
asked
uh i've got a question about protein
metabolism was looking at a paper uh
protein overfeeding resulted in no gains
in body fat even though the average
caloric increase was around 800 calories
so dylan was wondering if if there's
even a possible mechanism that that our
body can use to convert amino acids into
free fatty acids and then store them
ultimately as fat tissue so basically
the question was you know the root of it
there are a couple papers
uh
looking at very high protein over
feeding
and in those papers there's a curious
lack of fat storage so uh basically they
said hey you know have these really high
protein intakes we're talking upwards of
three or four grams per kilogram per day
so you know the rda for protein in
america the guideline says to shoot for
like 0.8 grams of protein per kilogram
of body mass per day we're talking about
in these over feeding studies three and
a half sometimes even close to four and
a half grams per kilogram which is a ton
of protein but in the course of these
studies these individuals who were free
living individuals
were instructed hey eat these really
high protein intakes but keep doing your
thing
lift some weights we'll see what happens
and so over the course of eight weeks
you know in one of these studies there's
really a series of three of these over
feeding studies by antonio and
colleagues
uh in one of them for example like the
uh the poster mentioned here
theoretically the high protein group was
eating like 800 extra calories compared
to the control group
and over an eight week span of time
they did not seem to accumulate any
additional fat mass compared to the
other group eating 800 fewer calories
and that is a really astronomical
calorie gap between group
between groups so before i get into
some of the applied research on the
topic the first part of the question was
is it even possible for us to really do
anything with these extra calories that
are coming from protein over feeding can
we use them for energy can we store them
for fat and the very simple answer is
yes
so um our body is pretty good at stuff
which is one of the reasons that there's
so much argument in the nutrition world
is because like
you can go on a really wide range of
diets and feel pretty okay and if you're
really excited about your diet you might
even feel great about it you know so
that that's why you you see so many
people saying i went virtually no carb
or i went really low fat or all animal
product or all plant product and
everybody's stoked about it and
everybody feels good yeah there are
about a half dozen different redundant
pathways to accomplish
virtually anything that you'd want to do
with very few exceptions like you know
essential amino acids there are a
handful that your body can't manufacture
itself most other things you'd want to
do related to energy metabolism there
are a lot of roads that that lead to
rome exactly so when our bodies breaking
down carbs a lot of times what we're
trying to basically get to the kind of
end destination is let's turn this into
some pyruvate or some acetyl coa and
let's plug those into the pathways of
energy metabolism we can throw those you
know we can do glycolysis with carbs
obviously we can also you know throw
that acetyl coa into the krebs cycle uh
use some of the products from there
throw them into the electron transport
chain we're using these kind of basic
foundational building blocks that
contain energy throwing them through
these pathways and getting atp as a
result and whatever's left over we can
find a way to kind of make sure that
we're storing fat when we have excess
energy and you know we can do so much
inner conversion because when we're
breaking down carbs we're breaking down
fats when we're breaking down protein
after we kind of strip the amino group
off of extra extra protein in the diet
you know we take that amino group off
and then we're left with what's left and
we can still turn that into pyruvate
turn that into acetyl-coa or it'll turn
into an intermediate that can go right
into the krebs cycle or the tca cycle so
when we're talking about metabolism of
carbs and fats and protein
it's kind of like dealing with currency
like we can exchange it when we need to
exchange it you're not gonna
end up with you know a huge amount of
currency and say ah it's the wrong
currency there's just nothing i can do
here there are exchanges that are
possible and we're ultimately breaking
it down into the same
energy containing building blocks that
we're throwing into pathways whether
those pathways are going toward uh
creating atp or we're just funneling
that towards storage for later use so
macro macronutrient metabolism is
extremely flexible
if we have a bunch of extra calories
coming in from fat we can deal with that
energy and the way we deal with it is we
either oxidize it for atp in the short
term or we convert it to something that
we can store for later and in some cases
that will be fat now
a lot of times people will look at these
types of questions and they will kind of
skip a step and go straight to pubmed
like i think there's a lot of value
we've talked about this before if you
want to get a good handle on general
metabolism you want to start at the
textbook rather than going straight to
the individual experimental evidence
right so sometimes i'll see people who
are like looking for experimental
evidence of protein getting directly
converted to fat for storage you want to
take several steps back get the lay of
the land for metabolism and then start
looking for what actually happens in
experimental conditions so a great
example that's analogous is a lot of
times people will
wonder if we can store extra carbs as
fat you know if you have a really high
carb diet and you're over feeding and
it's the same kind of question do we
have pathways where we can convert
carbohydrate into fat
and then store that sure we do but the
body would much rather
just burn off the extra carbs to the
extent that it can and just store the
dietary fat that's already fat so a lot
of times we'll see these really high
carb overfeeding studies
and experimentally it looks like there's
not a lot of conversion to fat
you know just straight conversion carb
to fat it doesn't mean it's not possible
doesn't mean we don't have the pathways
it's just the body is crunching the
numbers and saying i'd much rather just
oxidize the carbs and store the fat and
if i really must then sure i'll do some
conversion of carbs to fat so it's a
kind of a similar deal with protein
so yeah protein if we want to store it
as fat if we have to we can ultimately
convert it all the way down to like
acetyl coa and then do lipogenesis with
that acetyl coa and we can store it away
so that's the the short answer is yeah
if you're over feeding whether you're
over feeding carb fat protein whatever
there are going to be differences in the
pathways getting utilized in terms of
you know what our body prefers to do in
certain situations
the efficiency of fat storage will be
different so if you over feed with 800
calories worth of carbs versus fat
versus protein you're probably going to
have you know
just due to the thermic effect of
feeding the fat is going to get stored
very very easily
the thermic effect of carbohydrate is a
little bit higher we might not store it
with the exact same efficiency
and then protein has the highest thermic
effect so if you're going to say i'm
going to over feed no matter what with a
thousand extra extra calories on top of
what i'm already eating
what can i overfeed and have the
smallest relative amount of fat gain it
probably would go in that order right so
you you'd have an easier time storing
the most uh
most fat tissue coming from fat as a in
an overfeeding scenario slightly less
with carbs but it's kind of negligible
and then slightly less again with
protein do the due to the thermic effect
now
one thing that i think is important to
recognize when it comes to the specific
studies being mentioned here by antonio
and colleagues
this is no fault of the participants or
the researchers i want to say that uh on
the front end here
but
i am very skeptical
about the idea that there's these 800
extra calories and we simply don't know
where they're going i'm also skeptical
that it's just 800 calories of like
straight thermogenesis like that doesn't
line up well with our understanding of
metabolism and energetics i think what
you have to keep in mind with the
studies by antonio
is these are free living participants
and self-reported um
dietary data
so i think a really informative paper is
one by han and colleagues cody han is
actually one of our coaches at stronger
by science but they did a study where
they had three different overfeeding
conditions
and in one of them it was they were
trying to get people to just ramp up
their whey protein week over week over
week so they said like week one here
take some protein but week two and week
three and week four all the way to week
six they were supposed to increase their
protein intake by 25 grams every single
week
and what happened in that study over six
weeks and they did very very thorough
nutrition reporting
it just didn't happen uh like the people
started on high protein diets and if
you've ever tried to go from like a very
high protein diet to a very very high
protein diet
it's not fun no and like you would only
do it if you literally had to yeah so
like i mean they basically started
around like 175 grams a day of protein
and they were supposed to increase 25
grams every week for six weeks they
ended up getting to like 195 or 200 and
being like whatever dude i'm done and
actually their their total calorie
intake was lower than the other two
groups because
you know trying to force feed yourself
whey protein it sucks and it's also very
satiating so what you'll find is if
you're trying to give yourself a 300
grams of weight of protein a day mostly
coming from whey you're probably going
to find that you're not eating much else
because you're very very full
and unless someone's making you do it
you're probably gonna do that for like
three days and be like this sucks i'm
not gonna do this anymore so i've got a
story related to that i don't know if
i've talked about this on the podcast
before i i feel like i have but i'm not
positive
but uh back in the day
um
i was like maybe 19 or 20 or so i
learned about dc
like style bodybuilding like dog crap
training
and uh you know so i got into all of
that and there's nutrition
recommendations that go along with it
and i don't remember all of them but one
of the kind of bedrocks like one of the
cornerstones of nutrition advice in that
community is just like ah you know
regardless of the details just eat like
four or five hundred grams of protein
per day and everything else will more or
less sort itself out um so i was like
okay cool like i'll give that a shot uh
so i tried like i was tracking
everything and i was averaging something
north of 400 grams of protein for like
two weeks
and i just said [ __ ] that like i i can't
do this i i can maybe shoot for 300
grams per day uh and like i was in
college as well like i had a meal plan
um
but like the cafeteria didn't have many
like good relatively low calorie high
protein options so what my diet looked
like at the time is they had this little
salad bar where you could put like
little cubes of ham on top of your salad
and like deli ham is is pretty lean
so i would just like go and get a plate
and just load it up with like little
like tiny cubed ham slices and just eat
that with this or a little like ham
cubes and just eat that with a spoon um
which i imagine is probably more
satiating than whey protein and also ham
is very salty so i think i was gonna say
i hope that your blood pressure isn't
too responsive to dietary sodium no i i
don't think it is i don't think i'm like
a sodium blood pressure responder uh but
over just like the first week of doing
that i put on like eight pounds which i
think i think was 100 water retention
from how much deli ham i was eating um
but yeah that [ __ ] was [ __ ] miserable
dude yeah um
so anyone who is actually following that
dietary advice
i don't think you benefit from eating
that much protein but
if you are doing that and doing it
consistently uh you have a lot more
willpower to eat protein than i do
yeah yeah so
like i said there's a study by han and
colleagues which gives a window into
like what is the likelihood that a lot
of people really are
just going like four and a half grams
per kilogram per day and not having a
huge like
kind of like non-volitional reduction in
calorie intake uh or or at least just a
total replacement of their calories that
they were that would have been carbs and
fat just replacing that with protein i
mean when you look at really
meticulously reported studies like the
one by han and colleagues you'll see
it's not very typical for people to be
able to say oh yeah i'll just like
triple my protein intake or double it
and i'll just leave everything else the
same like it's not easy to do yeah um
and there's also a study by bray and
colleagues in 2012
where they did very rigorous
overfeeding with
varying levels of protein so like the
levels of protein were five percent of
energy up to 25 percent of energy which
i think spanned all the way from like
right around the rda like close to that
like point seven or point eight grams
per kilogram uh all the way up to like
three grams per kilogram and this study
was complete inpatient metabolic ward
every calorie that these individuals
consumed for the study period
and i think it was eight weeks which is
really impressive if that's the case
every morsel they ate was prepared and
provided by the research staff and every
instance of them consuming calories was
supervised by the research staff and in
that scenario there was nothing weird
about protein overfeeding there was no
like loophole where it's like man these
are like free calories
everything made sense in terms of the
amount of fat mass that was gained and
the amount of fat free mass that was
gained so
with protein over feeding
the closer you get to really tightly
controlled designs the more protein
overfeeding completely makes sense and
does exactly what you'd expect the
additional calories there's a little bit
of
increase in energy expenditure due to
the thermic effect of feeding that might
have a little impact on the propensity
to store fat just because of burning
calories nothing
biochemically weird about that
and then the fat free mass you know it
really just comes down to
you know if you're having a huge
increase in protein intake from a very
low protein diet you're probably going
to store some extra fat free mass just
because you were under eating protein
previously but uh yeah i know that there
are some studies floating around that
make it seem like there's some weird
biochemical stuff going on with protein
overfeeding almost like it's some kind
of biochemistry loophole that gives you
free calories it's really not the case
and unfortunately you know the calories
that are going in are going to be dealt
with either through an increase in
thermogenesis or
just storage of tissue so
uh that's it yeah so high protein over
feeding can it lead to fat gain
absolutely and that fat gain is very
much in line with what we would
calculate based on our understanding of
metabolism